los turistas que llegan al país saben
que no les conviene gastar con tarjeta
de crédito Por lo menos hasta ahora
porque un gasto en tarjeta les estaría
dando por cada dólar que gasten unos 150
pesos en cambio Si traen ese dinero en
efectivo y lo cambian en el mercado
paralelo reciben entre 290 y 300 Por eso
llegan con grandes cantidades de
efectivo por eso Esas imágenes de
turistas pagando cenas con muchísimos
billetes de pesos pero la decisión del
gobierno Busca en todo caso desalentar
esa alternativa y darle un beneficio del
turismo para que utilice plásticos
tarjeta de crédito tarjetas de débito
tarjetas prepagadas porque ahora lo que
prevén es darles el mismo cambio que les
da más o menos el mismo cambio que les
da el Paralelo es una ventaja es mucho
más fácil andar pagando con tarjetas de
crédito no ir con efectivo encima además
es una cuestión de seguridad no ir
cargando con efectivo es más seguro y es
menos engorroso hay que ver si
finalmente los turistas deciden
adoptarlo hubo otros intentos que no
funcionaron pero Hay muchísimo más engo
por ejemplo abrir una cuenta en
Argentina y depositar esos dólares aquí
y luego empezar a operar es algo que un
turista que viene por pocos días
Posiblemente no quiere hacer si este
mecanismo de las tarjetas funciona bien
y es adoptado por el turismo va a
permitir un mayor ingreso de Divisas al
circuito oficial en Argentina eso es
algo importante es algo que necesita el
país dólares en el circuito oficial se
estima que hoy entran tal vez unos 30
millones de dólares por mes de turismo
receptivo y se espera que con esta
medida si funciona bien llegue a los 200
millones O tal vez un poco más 200
millones de dólares por mes que entran
en el circuito oficial en Argentina